in the middle of the 19th century London
had a problem it had too many dead
people and not nearly enough burial
blocks recently deceased bodies were
having to be exhumed and then scattered
in order to make room for more people to
be put in the ground now that was
obviously an enormous health risk that
contributed to cholera epidemics which
in turn contributed to more deadly and
some to industrialists came up with an
audacious plan they would build York's
largest cemetery 20 miles outside London
improper and they would run trains from
there to here to this terminus here in
Waterloo and it would be the London
necropolis railway they'll be first
plaques funerals and second class
funerals and third class viewings which
at least guaranteed you a gravesite
which is a cut above the mass graves
that London was using at the time for
the dead that couldn't afford anything
better and here is the astonishing thing
the thing you might not know it worked
the London necropolis railway was a real
thing on nearly a century the first
train ran in 1854 and while the
motorcars starting to become popular did
diminish the service in the 20th century
it ran into World War two the only thing
that stopped it was the bombing out of
the railway tracks and this whole area
during the Blitz
if those tracks haven't been bombed out
theoretically we could still be seen
21st century first trains dying out
and that is something